hey guys it's Justine and we were the
Steve Jobs theater right now this is
where the actual keynote happened right
now they're having a special hands-on
event for apple arcade it officially
launches on September 19th for $4.99 a
month they're gonna have hundreds of
titles by fall but right now we're gonna
get a chance to check out some of the
launch titles so let's head in first
game free to play is skate city I like
your t-shirt oh we have three options we
have Barcelona Oslo and Los Santos Evans
our Los Angeles I don't know how to play
this so I'm just figuring it out as I go
okay I figured it already I'm doing
tricks but you would not believe I used
to love to do a pro skater you so played
on dreamcast back in the day this is
incredible this game is called sneaky
sasquatch so you guys might be new here
but my sister and I used to do this show
called watch watch watch watch so this
is a very fitting game if I were to make
a game I feel like this is what I would
make this raccoon is talking to me he
wants to talk to me if he sees us we'll
be in big trouble so let's practice this
is so amazing
I'm sorry oh no I'm getting in trouble
what we're doing here is essentially
trying to line up a little as square
shapes by doing that we'll get this
circle that's going around and to
actually touch it and get us to the next
level
there it is a Huard the next level
[Music]
okay that's really fine enough oh good
leg okay we have to play the way oh my
goodness okay this is super exciting you
guys may know that I am a huge like okay
[Music]
no I don't like okay I didn't I
Oh
[Music]
that legal brawl I absolutely love Lego
and I love everything Lego is doing to
push Lego into the next generation of
digital let's see one else up here at
the Apple or game oh this is fun oh I
was going the wrong way
oh my gosh this is so cool I love this
it's so cool because you're kind of
using the gyroscope to actually make the
control show where you point the iPad
that's where you go
is a trampoline my sis to be doing
parkour I definitely think that I am
[Music]
oh this is cool race very fast fail
spectacular be a boy and opens fire cool
alright I'm getting I'm getting the hang
of it this is like me in LA
four or five
so the building's left arcade and also
iOS or Tina's you could actually connect
a controller that's right now we're
playing the Apple TV version and I'm
going to be using an Xbox controller to
play on Apple TV I'm kind of speechless
you're playing the impossible road so
I've never played this before and I feel
like I'm doing quite well with y'all oh
boy things are happening I think I've
taken a shortcut or I'm made
have fallen off the track again
[Music]
somebody else go to play obviously you
can play on iPad on iOS on Apple TV but
you can also play on Mac so let's not
forget there are Mac gamers out there I
was one of them oh my gosh I remember
with Unreal Tournament came out for Mac
it was like lots of double check what
the year was but it was a long time ago
and it was the most exciting thing for
me and now here we are with Apple arcade
I am using a Playstation controller
laying on a Mac you know I definitely do
so do I take down yeah oh my gosh yes
I'm taking him with me okay so me and
the dog are getting in the car we're
escaping things are going very well I'm
in the car Bobby's in the car we've
escaped he's injured all you poor thing
but we're both injured we need to get
healed up I'm using a PlayStation
controller while playing on a Mac I was
just using an Xbox controller while
playing on Apple TV this is the future
we had so much fun playing games here
this is Jennifer my sister if you didn't
know she's always in my videos we're
awkwardly sitting in a chair because
it's super awkward so what was your
favorite game that you played I really
enjoyed this sneaky Sasquatch it was so
cute and we loved sasquatch Squatch
watch and the skater game because I
absolutely loved skating
it's just crazy because there's gonna be
so many games it's cool because you can
play on your iPhone your iPad
it's to be and he's a controller like
that is still something that is kind of
shocking to me I loved playing the hot
lotto game which was actually kind of
cool because you use the accelerometer
so you're kind of actually moving around
in the space I wish that we could play
them all we didn't get to but good news
is you can play soon shouldn't say it's
gonna be out soon
yeah we'll have enough time if you think
I'm talking fast it's because we have to
have you here for now
we do we have to go let's play one more
game and roll up so this is cool in the
keynote it may mention that all of the
audio that they record in this game they
actually did record it underwater that
is something that I would like to see
how they did that and that's it that was
just a quick look at Apple arcade
there's gonna be so many more fun games
coming out and I cannot wait so if you
guys wanna see more gameplay leave me a
comment subscribe like hits the bell and
I'm gonna walk up these magical steps
[Music]